So, how does it work for startup weekend next.
Well, after the weekend, it seems that you're told
that you're going to be presenting your results tomorrow
and the types of things we want to see is how big is this idea.
So, you have to understand that this is a note for the facilitators and coaches
Is while the business model canvass talks a lot about the business
the big idea and you need to note this.
The big idea is that there's thing external to the canvass that are important for a start-up.
It doesn't talk about competition. It doesn't talk about market size.
All of these external forces you need to be asking the team to present as well
and be constantly thinking about it.
Market size, we'll what kind of interest is this.
Is this is a large scalable opportunity or is it a hobby?
Or is it like a lifestyle business?
Now, those teams might decide that making 300 grand a year is just fine, thank you very much
but they ought to understand that they can never raise venture capital or even investment
and that it's a nice lifestyle business.
There's nothing wrong with that once you understand that that's the game you're in,
but you need to teach them the distinction between a scalable business and one that's a small business
Same for competition. Competition is not on the canvass.
They need to understand the external environment and they need to come in.
Understanding the proposed experiments to test each one of the segments
for customer segments, value proposition channel, and revenue model
and they want to know what the past fail signal is for each test
and more importantly you want these teams to hit the ground running
and so they need to come in with a 100 plus contacts
they're going to be calling on in the three weeks that they're in the class.
Where do they get the contact? Welcome to social media.
Friends, family, LinkedIn, Facebook, etc.
And since it's a team, there are multiple members of the team so a 100 contacts really isn't that much
spread among three or four or five people.
So you need to be able to contact them and they need to be roughly pre-qualified
So, each week the team will have homework.
You know, watch part of the Udacity lectures.
Fill out the business model canvass.
Talk to 10-15 customers and then talk to your mentor via Skype or Google hangout
and fill out the Launchpad Central software.